[音楽]
[拍手]
皆さんには夢はありますか
その夢は
叶えそうですか
私の夢は異文化の理解につながるような記事を書く
ジャーナリストになることです
私は岡山県の県北の小さな町ですが立ち
大学生になるまで外国の人は文化と接する機会がほとんどありませんでした
でも広い世界へのあこがれがあり
異なる文化が出会う場所では
何かワクワクするような新しいアイデアが生まれるのではないかと想像していたんです
子供の頃の性格は内気で人見知り0
ジャーナリストに向いているとは言いなかったと思います
でも私には夢がありましたからそんな自分をいくらでも変えられると思えたし
勉強することはすべて自分の夢につながると考え
朝起きて学校に行くのが待ち遠しい子供でした
そして誰もが自分を取り巻く環境や自分自身の性格を夢に向かって変えていくことが
できると信じていたんです
しかし
新聞記者になって2年目の時に
自分の力ではどうすることもできない国際情勢の変化の中で
夢への道を阻まれる人たちがいるということを知りました
清掃によってセックスと国の政治体制が変わったために
以前のように仕事や生活ができなくなり
に一つでボートによってそこでた
ベトナム難民の人々です
私は当時広島県の福山支局で勤務していたのですが
福山市沼隈町どゆまちにベトナム難民の一時滞在施設がありました
施設は県道から細い道に入りしばらく進んだ
山の中にありました
そこには難民という言葉からイメージしていた
2で切羽詰まった雰囲気はなく
払いゴミに包まれていたことさえありました
その中心にいたのが黒革愛子さんでした
近くに住む主婦だった黒川さん
2人のお子さんの子育てが終わる頃にこのセンターで働き始め
指導員を経て所長になられました
私がセンターの事務所を訪れると
難民の子どもたちがよく黒く朝に勉強を教わっていて
そこには本当の家庭のような
暖かな空気が流れ
センターの難民たちはいつも笑顔で私を迎えてくれました
でも欧米諸国への亭主を希望していた難民たちの中には希望の国に受け入れられるか
どうか分からず
センターでの滞在が数年にも及び
精神的に不安定になって自殺騒ぎが起こるというようなこともあったそうです
ベトナムからのボートピープルは75年から1975年から95年までの間に
13768人
日本に到着しました
多くは先に親類が定住し支援体制も整ったアメリカやカナダなどの国々での定住を希望
していました
しかしそれまでたくさんの難民を受け入れてきたこれらの国々が
門戸を狭め始める中
希望の国に定住できるのか
それでも日本に定住するのか
が決まるまでないだ
日本国内に多い時で二十数カ所あった
民間の一時滞在施設で難民たちは
生活しました
私が訪れていた日本赤十字広島県支部
沼来ます救援センターもその一つでした
センターでは77年から
17年間に
戦12の難民たちが暮らしました
私は
センターからアメリカに渡ったなぁ民たちが日本に対してどのような想いを抱き
どのように新たな人生を歩み始めているのか知りたいと思いました
そこで追跡取材をすることにしたんです
フルブライト奨学金のシーンを受けカリフォルニア州の大学で学びながら
センターから旅立ったが民たちをアメリカ各地に尋ねました
センターでは27人の赤ちゃんが生まれたのですが
この女の子がその一人です
96年当時7歳になっていたこの女の子には
3つの名前が付けられていました
ベトナム具のたを
英語のティガー
そして日本語の春です
お父さんの主さんは
ベトナム日本アメリカという3つの文化を忘れないでほしいからと話してくれました
1ナム語で日本インするにゃっとどういう名前が付けられた赤ちゃんも多かったそう
です
こちらの少年
9位君には彼が12歳の時センターのクリスマスパーティーで会ったことがありました
私がアメリカで取材した時には17歳の高校生になっていました
9位君とお母さんは
別々にベトナムを出た兄弟と4年ぶりにアメリカで合流し
一緒に暮らすことができるようになっていました
9位君はアルバイトをして家計を支え
たった一つ自分のために買ったのは日本語のテキストだと話してくれました
私がアメリカで訪ねた難民たちは
製粉支援を受けながら昼間働きよる専門学校や短大に通って
目標としていたコンピューターや美容系などの仕事に就いたばかりでした
子どもたちは一生懸命に英語を勉強し
渡米からわずか2年で地元の名門大学に入学したケースもあり
家族で支え合って
一生懸命あたら新しい生活を築こうとする姿が印象的でした
留学なと私は
外資系に通信社に移り東京で勤務するようになりました
そして2015年のある日
私の facebook に
3つのメッセージがアメリカから届いたんです
あなたは
20年前に僕たちを訪ねてきたジャーナリストではありませんか
9位君からでした
初めて会った時12歳だったクリ君は37歳になって
郵便局で働いているということでした
9位君が私のことを覚えていてくれていて
探し出してくれたことを
とっても嬉しかったです
9位君と同じボートでベトナムを脱出した110人はマドンナ号という船に救助された
のですが
彼らはいいなぁ
希望してゆくにに
定住しそれぞれの国で安定した型生活を築き
自分たちを110マドンナグループと名付け
これまでの道のりを振り返り
資料集め
助けてくれた人たちに改めて感謝するという取り組みを進めています
彼らを救助してくれたマドンナ号の乗組員と成長はフィリピン人の方々だったらのです
が一言お礼を言いたいと今も行方を捜しているのだそうです
こうして難民たちの it の糸が再びつながり
私は20年ぶりに黒かあさんに連絡を取りました
そして
海外や国内に定住した難民たちが
沼隈町位懐かしいんで黒かあさんの元を訪れるようになり
黒かあさんが
センターの後市や町の周辺を案内してあげているということを知ったんです
昨年来日した波は黒母さんにベトナムの民族衣装アオザイをプレゼントしました
この難民とは
センター出生以来全くなっていないのに細かな採寸を必要とするアオザイは黒かあさん
にぴったりだったそうです
何年も前にお世話になった黒かあさんの人形を当時と同じように思い出すことができた
んだと思います
この黒かあさんと難民たちとの30年に及ぶ交流は私たちに2つのことを教えてくれ
ます
一つは
夢屋2階を共有して築いた絆はその後の人生を支え続けるということです
難民問題は
祖国を出ざるを得なかった人々が再び安住の地に落ち月
家族とともに平穏な日々を取り戻して初めて
解決に向かえます
しかし自分や子どもの将来に希望を抱き
夢に向かって生きていけるそんな平和な社会では当たり前の環境が整うまでには長い
年月がかかるので
黒かあさんと難民たちがセンターで過ごした期間は長くても数年です
しかし黒かあさんの難民たちに寄り添う気持ち
その気持ちに感謝する心が積み重なり
センターを出た後の長い年月を経ても絆が続いていきました
この交流が私たちに教えてくれること
二つ目は
夢秋に外を共有できれば言葉や文化の違いは大きなハードルにはならないということ
です
言葉は通じなくても誠心誠意接すれば
思いは通じるんですよ
ドクロ母様言いま
センターで自殺は気が合ったとき夜中に駆けつけ
な民の気持ちが落ち着くまで側によりそうというようなこともあったそうです
飛行機が空を飛んでいるのを見たら
乗せられるものなら今すぐにでもあの飛行機に乗せて希望の国に行かせてあげたい
そう思ったそうです
この人たちの願いをどうか叶えてあげたいその一心だったと難民たちと過ごした日々を
振り返ります
現在
紛争や迫害のために祖国を追われた人々の数は6000560万人に上る
日本の人口の約半数です
皆さんの2人に1人が今この瞬間
波
そしてその半数が子どもです
私は子供たちが夢を抱き
夢の実現に向かって努力するということが
自分の力ではどうすることもできない理由で阻まれる世界であってはならないと思い
ます
そんな過酷な環境が生まれないように
紛争を解決し国際情勢が安定することも重要です
しかしもし難民という強軍になってしまった場合に
黒傘のように
夢屋2階に寄り添ってくれた人がいるという事実は子どもたちの将来にとって大切な
支えにな
私にとってこの取材の始まりは
センターの難民の現状を知りたいと言う
素朴な思いでしたいっ
そこから踏み出した一歩かっ
日本と難民の定住国とにまたがる壮大なストーリーへとつながっていったんです
まずは関心を持ち
行動を起こすこと
それが異文化理解の第一歩です
査定ジャーナリストになって四半世紀が経ち
私の夢は叶ったのかというと
叶ったという感覚はありません
仕事にはゴールがなく次はこうしようと思うことの連続です
最近は
夢がかなったと実感することは
ずっとないのかもしれない
優子と思います
でもクリさんがアメリカ後0
20年もの間
私が支えた希少大切に守っていてくれたことは
私にとって大きな支えになって
そして
黒かあさんと難民たちと思う
このまさに世界をつなぐ物語を
今こうして皆さんにお伝えできたことで
私の意味はほんの少し
実現に近づいたのかもしれない
思っています
ありがとうございました
堀江さんありがとうございましたた今日ははいと今日はあの黒革サンと後日本的10時
国際部の田中さんが会場にいらしてくれていますのでご紹介したいと思います
どうぞ
今日は本当に来お母さんは広島の方からあの
早朝に
おいでくださって田中さんはなるとあの
昨日まで
バングラデシュで炉辺や難民の救援に携わっていらっしゃったということで本当にあの
お忙しい中来てくださってありがとうございます
受けたから一言お願いします
担当している者がい m
でもあの
うまくはを故郷に
食べだった人たちが
幸せだリバース様という心からいつも願っております
今日アオザイを持ってきてくださいましたはいはぁんっ
[拍手]
黒かあさんは難民たちからお母さんという風に呼ばれていましてですね
先ほどの古澤さんの方からお話がありましたように
ミューチャル respect to
それかトラストと
言葉がですねまさにぴったりな人だと思います
生半可なことでは他の人に対してお母さんという言葉を使わないと思うんですね
そういう
スタッフと一緒に仕事できたことは私はとっても起こりですし
地雷あのアフリカ他いろんなところで活動して参りましたが
黒かさんと一緒に働いたですね日本でのベトナム難民の仕事というのは私の今の一番の
軸になっています
別の胸実はえええ
1975年4月30日にサイフォンが陥落して
2週間も経たない5月13日に最初の難民が日本にきました
今あの赤十字で
100人これまでですね数カ月の間で120人のスタッフが元気亭
活動しているわけですが一番難しいのが支援がなかなか集まらない
つまり無関心ということですね
で人道の敵は
無関心という風に
考えておりまして
ぜひ今日のこういった話ケーキですね
日本で波問題があったということをもう一回思い出していただいてですね
関心が広まればと思いますありがとう
お二人ともありがとうございました
それでは改めまして堀江さんありがとうございました
[拍手]